wir wollen sprechen mit menschen die
siegfried und roy kennengelernt haben
die sie privat kann nun zwar
schlagerstar heino und seine frau
hannelore sind nun live uns hier
zugeschaltet guten abend an sie beide
ja sie sie kannten das magier paar wie
haben sie ihre horn ja selber immer
erlebt
wir haben roy horn du dich erlebt also
erst mal als mensch nicht als künstler
und wir waren ja viel zusammen und wir
haben seine menschliche art geschätzt er
war zu mir und zu meiner frau handele
wie wie soll ich sagen wie ein wie ein
bruder und wir haben jetzt noch vor
anderthalb jahren meinen geburtstag
gefeiert in las vegas mit siegfried und
roy weil ich ja 80 jahre geworden bin
und wir haben ja und sehr gut noch
unterhalten und da war natürlich noch
gar nichts überhaupt nicht darüber
nachgedacht das mal hier eine krankheit
unserer freundschaft zu ende lässt
lassen geht und wir hatten noch nie
haben die auch immer so schön sagt ein
wunderschönes geschenk zu meinem
achtzigsten geburtstag konsequent
bekommen ein herz das was sie
zusammenschweißt
ein herz das nur zusammen schweiß und
unsere freundschaft ewig aufrecht erhält
glas ist war ein wunderbares andenken
aber wir werden euch sowieso immer in
unseren herzen bleiben und als wir sehen
uns sagt traurig und ich einfach ist
dann nochmal siegfried an berufen sowie
beide und haben unser beileid
ausgedrückt und er ist natürlich er ist
total durcheinander momentane sagt ach
ich sehe den jeder ecke esse ich mit mir
und hat gesagt
und natürlich können wir jetzt nichts
drüber reisen sonst sofort in den
nächsten maschine sitzen drüberfliegen
aber durch die karower zeit können wir
jetzt auch deine nach amerika reisen und
so wird also worum kleinsten
familienkreis und nun mit den
angestellten
diese hatten also zu grabe getragen und
wieder reißen können oder überhaupt
werden wir weil eine große feier macht
wurde zu bedenken royce was uns
ausdenken wenn alle freunde noch mit
zusammengerufen
auf jeden fall es ist traurig aber so
und ich denke über dran und ich hoffe
dass siegfried gut durch steht erst ganz
allein in diesem riesigen wunderbaren
lieber wäre
sie haben es gerade gesagt jetzt in
corona zeiten es natürlich besonders
schwierig jemanden beizustehen man darf
nicht hin wissen sie wo siegfried jetzt
ganz besonders halt findet wie er jetzt
trost bekommt in diesen schweren zeiten
ja ich glaube dass er das trost aus
aller welt bekommt und man muss ja man
muss sich ja mal vor augen halten die
waren über 45 jahre zusammen haben
weltkarriere erreicht und jetzt ist das
natürlich 15 15 jahren war die karriere
zu ende
siegfried hätte ja sich im grunde
genommen er war noch ja da sehr jung
eine andere karriere nach aufbauen
können mit einem anderen partner oder
als solist auftreten aber das hat er
alles nicht gemacht er hat zu seinen
zusagen den partner roy gestand bis zum
letzten atemzug und das muss man die
musik wird ihr auch hoch anrechnen
ich glaube dass das war vom sigrid wie
eine ehe die wurde ja auch er dann mal
zu bruch geht oder zu bruch gehen kann
aber ja bis zum letzten atemzug mit roy
das durchgestanden ist ein sieg wird ja
auch sehr anzurechnen dass er niemals
gesagt hat 15 16 jahren ich mache normal
nieder was anders da war ja auch noch 15
jahre jünger aber er ist natürlich hier
jetzt ist natürlich in der phase wo wir
ihn gar nicht
ja wo man sagen siegfried alte durch es
kommt man auch sehr wahrscheinlich
wieder bessere glückliche jahre auf dich
zu er wird wahrscheinlich nach berlin
und überall wir schon gestern sagte
überschatten und der passt noch nicht
auf und der un ja was soll man sagen es
ist grau beginnt wieder am liebsten bei
ihm sein und die hinter stützen aber was
diese kommune alles zustande kriegt dass
wir nicht verreisen können und nicht nur
unsere guten was besten freunde besuchen
können und mit dabei sein wenn die
letzte ehre erwiesen wird aber das
nachholen bestimmt vielen dank haben sie
beide sie uns diese sehr intime
einblicke in ihre freundschaft zu roy
horn gegeben haben vielen dank und
schönen abend an sie danke